the federal government's monthly
unemployment report just out this
morning
is a huge surprise after the damage of
the coronavirus pandemic the labor
department says the u.s economy
added two and a half million jobs in the
month of may and the unemployment rate
actually
fell to 13.3 percent this is a massive
turnaround from the historic job losses
recorded back in april and cbs news
business analyst jill schlesinger joins
us
jill what happened well it is just a
stunner as you said
and what we know is that as parts of the
economy
opened up some folks went back to work
now what's interesting about this is
food and drinking establishments 1.4
million jobs added so more than
half of this total there is some worry
that the
report itself is not capturing the true
picture of the labor market
in fact in the bureau of labor statistic
notes at the bottom of the report it
says that
part of that unemployment rate being
down at 13
or so could be understating
the issue that's because we're relying
on people to tell us
whether they are out of work for other
reasons or temporarily so
so the labor department actually says
the unemployment rate it could be as
much as
3 percentage points higher which would
actually be up over a 16
obviously what we know about 20 million
americans
have lost jobs as a result of the virus
it looks like
april will be the peak month for job
losses
that certainly would be good news we
hope that the the the peak losses are
receding
yesterday you and i were together and we
talked about initial jobless claims that
were i think 1.9 million in one week
alone
so how big is the lag between this
official report for the month of may and
these weekly reports we've been covering
every thursday
so the weekly report is last week this
monthly report
takes place in the second week of may so
it's a survey week that occurs
during the the week when the 12th day of
the month
occurs that's why some economists are
quite dubious about the actual reporting
numbers now that said
i'll take a little bit of positive news
here if we are seeing the market kind of
bottom out
that would be much better for all of us
but we really need to see
the subsequent revisions to these
monthly reports the labor department's
trying to work hard to figure out what
the true up numbers are
yeah yeah another question which i think
is top of people's minds these days is
if there is a rebound will the benefits
of that rebound be shared broadly i know
you just got the report you're only
going through it
as we speak but from what you can tell
are are different populations white
black old young
sharing in this turnaround this has been
a devastating labor market for people of
color black hispanic americans suffering
much more broadly if we look at the
overall unemployment rate again maybe
these numbers are going to be refined
but for black workers the unemployment
rate last month for all workers
was 16.8 percent for all
white workers that unemployment rate
12.4
the gap is stark tony
all right joe and the turnaround in
terms of joblessness also stark this is
from the looks of it on the surface at
least and we'll dig deeper
a positive turn of events on the jobs
front jill thank you very much